>> NI-LEWIS: Hi there.
I am Ian Ni-Lewis.
>> GALPIN: And I'm Dan Galpin.
And once again, we are here with another Friday
Games Review.
This is again a selection from your choices
from the moderator page.
This is the top five nominated games for us
to look at this week.
With us is also Alex over here who is acting
as producer and he's also going to be helping
us with the reviews.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Here, let's scooch over.
>> GALPIN: That's a good idea.
So, you know, Ian...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> GALPIN: ...what are we drinking today?
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you know, a lot of people
were asking me are you still going to drink
because you're having a, you know, this show
is so much later.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I'm like, "Dude, lunchtime."
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
This is even better.
>> NI-LEWIS: But I will say this I pulled
what we call, you know, our team pulling a
Galpin.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Last night--I was up all night
doing something that wasn't actually all that
useful.
I was, you know, I was actually making that
intro video that you just saw.
>> GALPIN: But isn't that intro video awesome?
>> NI-LEWIS: I love it but...
>> GALPIN: It is certainly worthy of my name
[INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely but...
>> GALPIN: So, I'm totally pleased to be so
in any way.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, because Dan will do this
to be like, you know, God, I was up 14 hours
straight last night and I made this, you know,
model of The Great Wall of China for my dental
fillings and it didn't actually...
>> GALPIN: That was an amazing model [INDISTINCT]
I mean.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
So, the upshot is...
>> GALPIN: [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...we're both tired...
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...because I pulled the Galpin,
he is a Galpin.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
Exactly.
>> Ni-LEWIS: But that's--we're not going to
let that stop us.
It's noon.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that means a lunchtime beer
but I will say this because I pulled a Galpin,
I was unable to pull a Lewis--a Ni-Lewis...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and stop by some awesome liquor
store for beer so, I had to pull what's in
the fridge.
Fortunately, we had a pretty good selection.
From my--what I consider my adopted hometown
of Renton, Washington.
We have Redhook ESB.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Great brewery.
We've both been there.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Not at the same time although
we did eat at The Herbfarm right next door.
They have a wonderful patio and you just sit
out there next to the brewery...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...eat some broths, drink some
ESB and life is good.
>> GALPIN: That's what we need to bring actually
is some broths onto the show to go with the
beer.
And that would just make the show that much
better.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right bro--broth.
So, we're drinking ESB.
Now I brought a [INDISTINCT] for Daniel Pham
our engineer just in case.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But I have something super special
for...
>> GALPIN: Ooh.
>> NI-LEWIS: There you go.
>> Hey, guys.
>> GALPIN: Hey.
>> NI-LEWIS: Hey.
Nice.
I have something super special for producer
Alex.
>> GALPIN: Ooh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because Alex didn't get to go
to Mobile World Congress this year.
So, I brought him back a taste of Barcelona.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Estrella Damm.
>> GAPIN: Damm.
>> NI-LEWIS: The Damm stands for damn, Estrella
again?
Seriously?
You guys don't serve anything else in this
town?
>> Interesting.
>> GALPIN: Pretty much.
>> NI-LEWIS: All righty.
Let's take a look...
>> GALPIN: Is that [INDISTINCT], right?
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Okay.
Well, now we've wasted a lot of time and the
haters are going to hate on us so, let's get
right to it.
>> GALPIN: All right.
So, the first game we're going to look at
and here yeah, we have our exciting intro
graphics here.
And I could hit it one more.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, no.
Really?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Yeah, and...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh.
>> GALPIN: That one.
There you go.
Oh, all right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
All right.
>> GALPIN: All right.
So, the first game we're going to be looking
at is Agent Shooter.
And actually go to the next slide so that
we can take a look at Agent Shooter's--there
we are.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: So, Agent The Shooter lets you
know from the beginning that it's ad-supported
just in case you were wondering whether or
not it was free or paid or not.
It's right there in the title.
>> NI-LEWIS: It also lets you know quite clearly
from the feature graphic that this is done
but like one dude who has GIMP.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
Someone who's knows how to use the filters
and now they're Photoshop or GIMP but it certainly
looks like GIMP to me.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: And, yeah, but that being said,
it's actually quite a lot of fun to play I
think.
>> NI-LEWIS: It really is.
You know, I felt like this is just the kind
of game that Android needed.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a shooter game.
It's...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's basically like a...
>> GALPIN: A shooting gallery game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah, it's a shooting gallery
like Are 51 or something, right?
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You're just going through and
the multi-touch makes it really cool.
You can actually multi-touch different targets.
But it's completely unrealistic...
>> GALPIN: I figure I just have...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I think.
>> GALPIN: I think I have just five guns in
my hand actually is what I look at it.
>> NI-LEWIS: That makes sense.
One for each finger.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, one--I'm--exactly.
I'm a shooting alien, that's what I am.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Your fist has five guns.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Nice.
>> GALPIN: Well, that's a Galpin.
So, we have here the title screen of Agent
Shooter and, you know, there's really not
much to say about this other than my God,
there's a lot of stuff on here and where is
it?
>> NI-LEWIS: Where's the images?
Are we waiting for the images to load?
>> GALPIN: It felt like I...
>> NI-LEWIS: Surprising enough, yeah, yeah.
>> GALPIN: I actually said you're looking
at it for about two seconds thinking this--no,
this is it.
Okay.
Well, there you go.
But that being said, you know, you can get
right into the game here.
And now you see I've unlocked episode one
which shows you how much I've actually managed
to play on this tablet.
But let's go start this.
And again, the game itself is really, you
know, from a--it's not really designed for
a tablet, let's just be honest here in terms
of graphical fidelity.
But as I said, it's actually fun to play and,
you know, I usually play with two fingers.
But it's actually almost like, you know, being,
you know, two guns.
It's somewhat realistic and other than I could
never shoot this well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I actually feel like the
graphics on here totally remind me of Area
51 and this is like that, you know, state
of the art for arcade machines in the late
'90s sort of graphics.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
And, you know, it is actually--it is actually
really fun, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: It doesn't give a lot.
You can see that you got the accelerometer
going, you've got the ad at the bottom.
It's all pretty unobtrusive.
Now it, you know, on a tablet, I was going
say that is really, really small.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: So, it's really, really nice and
you get a new high score.
It asks your name all the time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Fair enough.
Now one thing that I noticed immediately about
this game is that they do allow you to shoot
multiple things at once.
So, you tap multiple targets.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But there is one problem and
it's tough to tell on the video because as
you know...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...the man won't let us play
sound from these games but if you did hear
sound from it, you would notice immediately
that it clips really badly.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: They've cranked up the audio
for each individual gunshot and that means
that playing multiple shots at the same time
is sure to clip.
This is tough especially if you're just trying
to crank out an Android game quickly.
You're probably using SoundPool.
That would be my choice for this type of game.
>> GALPIN: Sure, yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: The problem is you've got to
do one of two things.
You either have to make sure that your volumes
are normalize so that none of your sounds
are going to clip even if play five or six
over the top of each other or you need to
go the extra mile and add some effects.
I mean the thing that you need for this--this
is what we use in broadcastings, what we use
in music, what programs to use is something
called the compressor limiter.
It's a very, very easy thing to make mathematically.
I actually wrote an article in Game Programming
Gems 8, I think...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...on the compressor limiter
that I wrote for Halo 3.
We actually cranked that thing and used it
for a radio effect but what you want to do
is get it so--the high parts of the sound
just kind of roll off...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...so, that you don't ever blow
your eardrums out or in this case, blow this
blow the speakers because you're clipping
so hard.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, and I think it's a, you know,
you can control attenuation in SoundPool.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: So, that's, you know, and that's
the other way to do it is you can, you know,
given the fact that you have it, you know
a maximum of the sounds that you're going
to be playing at once.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: It's a little tricky because SoundPool
actually doesn't give you any knowledge that
your sound is really playing and necessarily.
So, you do--it is a little bit tricky but
I think that the easier thing to do is to
try to lower the sound volume a little and
or, you know, you could go the extra mile
and actually write your own mix or with effect
process or you can do it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, but at the very least,
you know, do what you used to do when we didn't
have good computers to play games on and write
yourself a fake compressor.
So, basically what you're trying to do is
based on how many sounds you've played...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...within a certain period of
time, just drop the volume down.
You drop it down a certain amount for each
sound and then you let it come back up slowly,
you know, just write a little, you know, windowed
average engine to do that.
So, but the main thing is, you know, make
sure especially if you're going to be playing
a lot of sounds, you know...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...this would have been very
easy to test and surprising to me that the
developer let it shift and just stay.
>> GALPIN: Well, you know, again this is a--this
game is--it's really cool.
It's clearly one guy and, clearly, you know,
that was not his priority with sound effects
I mean.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true.
That's true.
>> GALPIN: But the image is really fun and,
you know, again there's just a lot of UI stuff
here.
You know, it's hard to tell how much this
is tablet specifics and I only got to play
this on the tablet.
Yeah, one thing that's interesting is that
it's actually sort of a wizard that goes on
as you're going through the levels and it
is a little bit jarring given the kind of
composition of different elements that we
see here on the screen at once.
We have one like some Android elements, some
Bitmaps, some sort of Bitmap creations of
similar Android elements and, you know, it
does feel like there's--at this point it will
make sense to actually bring in a designer
and have them take a look at all of these
intro screens because the game itself is really,
really fun and you don't want someone to go
through at the first screen of the game be
"Wow, this feels really amateurish.
We should, you know, I'm not interested."
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you just have to ask yourself
a question "Are you selling to the public
or are you selling to like your friends and
family."
Because your mom doesn't really care, right?
But anyone who doesn't know you...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...that--well, yeah, your mom
sure but we all know.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: …digs that.
The problem is anyone that just downloads
this game, and remember they probably downloaded
several games.
They're probably looking for a good game.
They're probably going to give you a few seconds
to prove yourself and unless they're really
looking for this specific game, they're probably
going to be a little turned off by the presentation,
the production values.
Especially when there's a lot of games out
there that are just as free as this one and
are just as fun as this one that have better
production values.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, I know.
And another minor thing, you know, I would
love to see, you know, the Hallow theme at
least turned on.
You know, it's good.
You actually--guys, you actually are, you
know, don't have the compatibilities and,
you know, all that kind of stuff on there,
but it's always kind of sad when you're on
a tablet these days and you're seeing all
those, you know, Gingerbread theme, you know,
sitting on there.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's true.
>> GALPIN: That's all right.
And they're not so easy to do.
Just buy in and going in and actually making
sure you're targeting the most recent [INDISTINCT]
levels and just triggering the Hallow theme
for in this case, you want dark.
But which is the default I believe.
But that's pretty much it, you know, and I'm
not going to go into kind of great detail
here but...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
No.
It's a fun game.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
It really was.
>> NI-LEWIS: The mechanics--I don't know why
there aren't more games like this.
This is a lot of fun.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
And actually...
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Let's go ahead and move on.
>> Before you do, YouTube would like to know
what you guys thought of the music for that
game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, the truth is that we played
it with the sound off.
Except for the--wait.
No.
That makes no sense.
We didn't play it with sound off.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: We played it with--I don't know.
The guns were clipping really hard.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, I don't remember music.
There was music.
>> NI-LEWIS: Was there music?
>> I assume there was.
>> GALPIN: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Look at this.
I love this--it's like just beautiful demonstration
of exactly where me and Dan are.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: At 12:00 PM.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: By 2:00, we're rolling.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right now though, we're like
[makes sound] yeah.
>> GALPIN: [makes sound].
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
All right.
Come on.
>> GALPIN: All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Head in the game, dude.
Head in the game.
>> GALPIN: All right.
So we're going to go next to Sliceween.
>> NI_LEWIS: Sliceween.
>> GALPIN: All right.
I'm just going to go...
>> NI-LEWIS: Just--yeah.
Just a little early for Halloween.
>> GALPIN: It is just a little early, but
you know...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
It's almost October.
>> GALPIN: This game actually has...
>> NI-LEWIS: You know...
>> GALPIN: ...amazing production values on
here, on the [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: It is pretty good.
Yeah.
It's a nice game.
I know, this is one of those games that I
think it was being kind of the Adobe Illustrator
game where the...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...graphics--it's like obviously
somebody made the graphics that has real talent.
You know, the gothic graphic designer, but
then they made like one frame.
You know, there's no actual animation, there's
just a bunch of [INDISTINCT] transformations.
>>GALPIN: Yes.
Yeah.
Well, you know, clearly they--and this is--again,
this is--certainly if you have the choice
between having really, really awesome, you
know, a single really awesome frame and none
of it, this is the way to go.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely, that's true.
>> GALPIN: But it is what differentiates it
from some of the other physics games out there
that have been really, really successful.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: I'm like--and, you know, right
now, the bar's pretty high in physics games.
People have a lot of choices.
There's been a lot of really successful games.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: And so, you know, again, great
presentation, but, you know, the kind of the
bar has to be up here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And as far as upping the bar I--well, you
can see with the game play.
I didn't feel like it had a significant amount
to offer.
I mean I feel this is exactly like heaven
and hell.
Wow.
Really?
>> GALPIN: But--yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And so basically the idea is, you're going
to slice through one or more pieces of, I
don't know, wood I guess.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that's going to make your
bat roll around until he falls into the haunted
house.
>> GALPIN: Right.
And you have to get--both get the bat into
the haunted house and you have to, you know,
collect as many pumpkins as possible.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And like I'm saying this--we saw a game last
year, it was called Hellrider or Angels and
Demons or...
>> GALPIN: Something like that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Something like that.
One of those Dan Brown type titles.
And it was exactly this game, but it had like
an extra twist because there were angels that
behave the way the bat does and then there
were demons that did something completely
different that escapes me at the moment.
So, nothing wrong with the game playing, it
was certainly fun.
It just doesn't really bring anything new
and as you can see the amount of animation
is really low.
So, you're not really tempted to identify
with this bat or fall in love with the bat
or think of them the way that you would, let's
say as, you know...
>> GALPIN: Well, you know, and again, a lot
of times these games have actually gone through
a whole bunch of phases of, you know, modification
with characters and part of the reason that
they modify as well as characters is people
actually connect with those characters, and
a lot of people identify with those characters
strangely enough.
Even what you're doing is flinging those characters
into a brick wall, you're still somehow identifying
those characters and...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>> GALPIN: And so, you know what, that's always
nice to.
And yeah, I think that is kind of what the
game is missing is animation.
But--because the game is otherwise quite good.
This is another thing.
You know, this dialogue is cool, wanted.
I'd love to see it be a Hallow dialogue into.
I'd love it.
I love to see it actually, you know, in this
case, be a theme dialogue.
It makes sense to have these things kind of
themed around the game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you know...
>> GALPIN: You can see with all the other
presentation [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you know what--we were
just talking--Rachel and I were just talking
about this last hour in the app review that
there are some apps where you can tell that
they had a great designer and then you can
also tell that they ran out of time before
they shipped.
And you can just map out exactly where they
ran out of time.
Now, in this case, I'm not sure if it's running
out of time or just not caring about it.
Obviously the main screens all look great.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, why that random dialogue
popping up?
That just looks ugly.
I don't know.
I can't explain that.
>> GALPIN: That was bad.
Totally.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
It was.
You suck at this game.
>> GALPIN: I totally do.
I totally do.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, fun game; could be better.
I think that there's other games out there
that are equally good and maybe more interesting.
>> GALPIN: But, you know, it's certainly--it's
also interesting to get a Halloween themed
game and, you know, at this time of year,
but I think it's one of those things, you
know, the team is always looking for strange
things to have around Halloween.
I think that might resonate with, you know,
the team, you never know when in terms of
when you're looking at stuff.
>> NI-LEWIS: I wouldn't be surprised if Google
Play featured this game.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's history because it's--there's
certainly nothing wrong with it.
I mean, if you're going to ask me, "Are you
going to spend your hard earned dollars on
this?"
Well, no, but I guess all I'm really spending
is my hard earned time.
Still no, but I could see that some people
would.
Now, speaking of featuring it, they do have
a reasonable good feature graphic...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...in the sense that it's legible.
And when you make that thing very, very small,
you will still be able to read the word "Sliceween."
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a little crowded, honestly.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, got the moon, you got
the haunted house, got the, you know, that
haunted house stuff isn't really going to
come through, those pumpkins in the bottom
are--I mean why are they even there, you know,
this is one of those things where...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
In terms of the features, I think that you're
certainly going to see the bigger pumpkin
on the bottom.
You know, it's okay.
You know, I think the bats are just really
quick noise at the top, I agree, but it looks
good on the [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and you're going to have
a really hard time seeing that that's even
a bat because if you look at contrast between
the black bat wings and the red sky, it's...
>> GALPIN: It's a little bit too low, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: It should definitely go with--you
look at the kind of bottom of the red sky
that you have here in the game, you can switch
back to it--to the tablet for a second.
Actually you can.
It's a good question though.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
I can now.
>> GALPIN: You can, yeah.
So you look--if you look, you see there's
this very bright orange sky at the bottom.
That'd actually be kind of a better color
to be against the back of the bat.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It's tough.
Let me...
>> GALPIN: In terms of [INDISTINCT] graphic.
>> NI-LEWIS: The main thing is that when you're
selling this game to people, you first need
to sell it to our merchandising team and that's
very, very important.
Because if they see something, if they're
like, "Well, if we put this in store window,
it's not going to sell."
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Then they're going to back off.
And this is--you know, there's nothing exactly
wrong with it, but it could use a once over
by someone who knows how to put together an
ad as opposed to just like a collage of game
elements.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
So, I think that's about it for Sliceween
right now.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You can always revisit it later
if we don't run out of time.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, I think we're going to look
at Candy Racer next.
Now Candy Racer is a much better example of
a feature graphic in some ways and maybe not
quite as good in other ways.
The--you know, it's got one clean graphic
that makes the game look fun.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Arguably more fun that it actually
is.
The Candy Racer logo is beautiful and big.
It needs to be a little bit bigger.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
It could be a little bit bigger and it--you
know, and it's great having the developers'
names there, but they're not going to read
it all, but that might be okay if they don't
read it all on the phone.
I mean they know it's...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It's--that's not a huge deal.
I mean it's not--it's not important information
in the sense that it would be a make break
for your buying decision.
>> GALPIN: Now, they're not feel to read free.
If you do want to--you know, that's probably
the biggest thing, if you do want free to
be an important element when they're, you
know, when it gets featured on the phone,
you know then that would definitely be something
you'd want to--you'd want to, you know, highlight
a little bit more or just get rid off and
make it--you know, it will be very clear the
user said it's free, it's okay.
It's kind of a--it's a good question because
I'd--you know, making it clear to users that
it's free probably is going to improve the
chance to actually click on it, but I don't--I
don't know.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's quite true.
Although in general, we do tend to feature
the paid version anyway, but, yeah.
So Candy Racer is--nothing wrong with this
game.
It's a good game.
Like you said the title screen is great.
I can't say enough about this, you know, you
can see that someone took a long time just
thinking, "What is fun about this game?
What is--what is the experience that I want
people to think they're having with this game?"
>> GALPIN: Well, and, you know, actually the
one thing I really love the trail that's actually
shown behind the car and I kind of wish that
was a game element.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: And then you start going fast you
could see like a little trail speed up behind
the car.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
That would be--Well, you kind of do.
I mean there's a little particle system there.
>> GALPIN: There is.
>> NI-LEWIS: This is not, woah.
>> GALPIN: I know how to deal.
Oh, I'm sorry.
But I think I maybe I have to stop tapping
on it?
>> NI-LEWIS: You have to.
You can't tap when you're going uphill.
>> GALPIN: Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Little tip from producer Alex.
He's a pro at Candy Racer.
>> Yes.
They technically tell you this in little splash
screen...
>> GALPIN: They do.
>> ...at the beginning of the level but I
saw the thing.
It says tap to go fast and skip right passed
it.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> And then...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's always a danger.
>> Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> And then it actually took me three or four
tries on the second level to figure out why
it couldn't execute the loop perfectly.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> Because I was pressing down when it was
going up and then the car always flop over.
>> GALPIN: Yup.
That's exactly who does [INDISTINCT] all the
time.
The game is, you know, you've got a pretty
good level of challenge to it and, you know,
I think the presentation is good.
I mean, this is actually, you know, example
of really doing a lot of things right.
It does play audio on the lock screen which
a little unfortunate.
And it's a definitely something to look at.
That's really, really easy to fix by looking
at whether or not your window is currently
active.
>> NI-LEWIS: The other thing that I just want
to mention is when you're designing games
for a mobile environment.
You have to remember that you'll very frequently
get played in environments that are not at
all optimal.
And this game in particular suffers from that
because some of its screens have extremely
low contrast.
You can see this on this screen with all of
the white lettering.
It's very, very difficult to read if you're
at all in sunlight or if you have poor lighting
conditions at all and maybe think about doing
a little bit more contrast from those.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
It's--if the drop shadow was maybe a little
bit stronger it will be able easier to read.
There's also a little bit of resolution going
on here too at the screen.
It's just the tiny bit and too low for this
device.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: And it's noticeable.
Another thing that we're seeing here which
is--which is interesting is, you know, I don't
know if we unplug it whether we see that.
But there is actually letter boxing on the
right-hand side of the screen here.
Which is kind of unfortunate because I don't
really see any reason why there--what the
needs to be there.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
It's not the kind of game that needs to be
a letter boxed at all.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
And so...
>> NI-LEWIS: And it's...
>> GALPIN: ...I was surprised.
Let me--let me unplug the HDMI so we could
just, you know, lose the feed here.
I just want to see...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
Okay.
>> GALPIN: ...unplug.
Yeah.
Still somewhat letter box.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: It's just letter box.
You don't get more letter box, yeah.
>> GALPIN: So, you know, that's what I thought.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
This is--this one other thing is really frustrating
because when you see a game like this you
know that what happened is they authored it
some random resolution as probably...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you know, from a different
flat form.
>> GALPIN: No.
This is...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: This was--this was an AndEngine
game.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's an AndEngine Game.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, yeah.
It's just--it's just not typically right now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, in that case there's no
excuse, whatsoever.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: I see.
That's what I say.
>> NI-LEWIS: The other--no, I want to talk
about game play for just a second.
And sort of revisit what you're saying about
the trail, right?
So, I'm thinking to myself, why is it that
Alex, Dan and I all had exactly the same experience
which is we were like pushing on that thing
to trying get it up the hill.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I think a lot of it is because
all of the feedback is when you tap on these
things sparks shoot [INDISTINCT] is out of
time to end and that's--to me that says go
faster.
Other games have dealt with this differently
like, you know, we look at the monster truck
game last week and its controls were more
center around tilting forward and back.
And maybe having the car, you know, tilt forward
and back or something would make more sense.
Like, "Oh, if I'm tilting into the hill its
going be slower.
I don't know."
>> Yeah.
I think we were all subscribing in the mental
model of pushing down implies pushing down
on gas.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> And what it actually was pushing down exert
some sort of force of gravity on the car.
You can especially tell if the car is mid-air
and you push down on the screen and the car
like starts dropping even though it's in mid-air.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> ...it some sort of gravitational constant
thing which is not especially intuitive.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And it...
>> But it is for interesting game play mechanic
once you understand this.
>> NI-LEWIS: See, that's the thing.
I think the mechanic is fine.
I think the issue is since it is non-intuitive
you have to give your players a little bit
more in the way of hints or explanations.
You know, maybe if it's a gravitational constant,
why not put a rocket on the car and pointing
into the air and fire that thing every time
you push down.
I mean, something that will make it obvious
that I'm getting a, you know, a G-force out
of this thing rather than a rotational force
on the wheels.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I think--I think even some indicator would
be really useful too like I mean...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...you kind of make it clear that
what you're doing is actually manipulating
gravity because that is pretty...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...close.
The closest thing I can see in what you guys
are doing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and especially when you
think about other games of this type, you
know.
For instance, one of the things that you want
to do in a lot of games is let off the gas
if you're--if you find yourself catching air
up a hill.
In this game, it's exactly the opposite.
If you're catching air up a hill you want
to tap so you can fall back down to the--to
the hill and catch those stars.
So, it is a good mechanic.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: It is fun.
It's a fun game.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But it's frustrating to learn.
And I think it could be less frustrating if
there were a little bit more acknowledgement
that this is none-intuitive mechanic.
There's...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...something in there to give
you intuition about what's going on.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
And the game is very hard.
I will definitely say that, you know..
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...like even just getting making
progress to level is actually so much challenging.
I would probably take a slight tone down of
the challenge to get through to level and
really focus people on getting all of the
stars.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: Because I'm getting the Candies.
Because that--I think that's actually one
of the secrets to Angry Birds' success.
It's actually relatively easy to make through
out of the levels.
I mean don't get stuck very often.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: But then there--then there was
that extra challenge for the more hardcore
gamer of actually going through and trying
to gold star every level.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, I think...
>> Well, I didn't--I didn't notice this the
first time through but the stars are actually
points their time.
So, you get a second for every star you get.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> Which makes for an interesting mechanic
because your scored on how much time you have
when you get to the end of the level.
>> GALPIN: Right, right.
>> Which you then as the player have to balance
between how fast that you shoot through.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> ...and how much care you take in like dropping
down and click the stars versus just catching
air and trying to, you know, skip [INDISTINCT]
an entirely.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I think what Dan is saying
is, you know, that's fine.
It's good mechanic.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But there's more replay.
People will play a level more often to three
star it than they will to pass it.
If they just get stuck and can't pass the
level.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Then they may stop playing the
game all together.
But if they can't three star the level...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...hey, you know.
I've had some levels where I go back 20, 30
times until I've gotten all the score I could
possibly get.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> But there is bronze, silver and gold for
the level depending on how much time you have
left.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: At the bronze is actually--I think
it will be a little easier to get to the bronze
level.
>> Okay.
>> GALPIN: That will be my--that will be my
feedback.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
My advice would be, you know, the bronze are
way, you know, there's some level where it's
like, "Yey, you got to the end finally."
And that, you know, give people away to get
to the next level without actually getting
to the target you see that for bronze, silver
and gold.
>> GALPIN: All right.
So, let's go to the next game which is GSN
Casino.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
So, GSN Casino is a slot machine game.
We love slot machine games.
We cannot get enough of them.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
You know, it's--the truth is that slot machines
are very, very easy games to write a basic
version of it and there hard game that actually
balance well.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
They're also very, very popular.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: They just--they don't really
hit our demographic.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Our meeting in my demographic.
Not...
>> NI-LEWIS: Or...
>> GALPIN: ...our meeting Google Play.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Right, right.
>> GALPIN: Google plays...
>> NI-LEWIS: No, no.
Google Play, yeah, yeah.
Now, it's just tough because there isn't anyone
that works in Google that likes slot machine
games.
I don't know why.
>> GALPIN: I'm sure there's someone that works
here but no one that I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because we're not retired.
>> GALPIN: That's possible.
And it is more than just a slot machine game.
Let's be fair.
There's, you know, there are--there's video
bingo and video poker as well, but it basically
a video casino simulation.
>> NI-LEWIS: See.
This I don't understand.
It is--under what circumstances would you
play this?
Because, you know, I can see going to Vegas
and dropping a little bit on the slot.
But when you're doing that you at least get
free drinks, right?
>> GALPIN: But we're already getting free
drinks for playing the game right now.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true.
That's why.
>> So, you're saying that we should hook this
up to a [INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
That would make a much better.
>> Yeah.
>> GALPIN: So, in any event I'm going to...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So, at least you've got some variety, right?
Yeah.
And that's actually been my complaint about
a lot of slot games is it feels like a slot
games will build an engine and then just reskin
it over and over and over again.
Whereas in a real casino, of course you get
some of that certainly.
There's a ton of slot machines that are just
reskins of each other but the games that are
actually making money are the ones that have
some sort of hook to them.
That's different from other slot games.
And they do try to at least design things
differently.
If it's exact same like 21 line combo, you
know, lines going everywhere, you know, you
can play coins in different ways but the patterns
are all exactly the same that like this, right?
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, I've seen a lot of
games where all they--all they would do is
take something like this and change out the
background art and call it a new game.
And that's no fun at all.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I think, you know, for slot machines, I think
that the--I--what I really want to see is
someone taking it to the next level.
Doing things you can't do in Vegas or you
won't--that people won't do in Vegas for various
reasons and actually going, you know, kind
of going...
>> NI-LEWIS: Like holding up the casino and
stealing thing--you're...
>> GALPIN: Well, you know, that would be entertaining,
actually.
I wouldn't mind...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...counting cards.
>> GALPIN: I wouldn't mine a whole 3D FPS,
you know, built in to the casino game, but,
you know, but, you know, more than, you know,
in terms of, like, these bonuses, like ,you
can really spend time on them because this
isn't just a game.
We are trying to steal as much money from
people as possible.
Yours is a game we're you're actually trying
to entertain at the same time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: So, you can really take things
to the next level.
You don't have to worry.
Well, the bonus round takes 30 seconds, that's
30 seconds where the machine is in use.
You can say, "That should take three minutes
to get to the bonus round."
And you do a lot of things if it's interesting.
You're not also as concerned about payouts,
you know, in a casino, you know, and these
games are usually paying out like at 95%,
you know.
So you're going to--because you want people
to continue participating and playing, you
know, buying in occasionally but feeling that
they are getting value by comparison because
they're going to...
>> NI-LEWIS: You could payout a hundred and
ten percent if you wanted to.
>> GALPIN: You could but then you might have
no one--then you would most likely not have
anyone buying anything unless you would be
monetizing ads only.
So, most of the time, you know, these are
monetizing the same way casinos do in the
sense that you are, you know, ultimately buying
tokens here, you know, eventually I will run
out of [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Buying tokens then running out
them, you know.
>> GALPIN: So--but, you know, it's a decent
game I would like to--that I just want...
>> NI-LEWIS: But it is cool.
I mean--and actually, this game is really,
really god example of what I'm talking which
is, you know, you've got like the Cannon Barrage
that comes up and all these little things
that make this feel like a different game
than the next game or the game after that,
you know...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's not just a bunch of different
artwork that you pulled off of like Shutterstock.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I mean the one thing I would say about this
is that they're--the--like the resolution
is good but it's still noticeably blurry on
this tablet especially the text, you know,
and so--and my general--my general feeling
is--actually the backgrounds here are fine
but I would--when you see, like, Jolly Roger
and Cannon Barrage, you can really, really
see some filtering going on there.
And it just makes your eyes try to focus on
it.
It's also kind of weird because it's a graphic
but the kerning on Roger just kind of irks
me when I look at it.
It's like the R looks like it's--it's several
pixels farther away than the rest of the characters.
And if you're going to go through and you're
going to--going to do artwork for your text,
it's just--make it look really good because
right now it looks like a combination of blurry
and a little bit, you know...
>> NI-LEWIS: You--you're such a font geek.
>> GALPIN: I am such a font geek.
It's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: But, yeah, it is just a darn
shame to have, you know, a bad resolution
on a tablet like this because let's face it,
tablet games are, you know, games on tablets
are far more popular than games on phones
and this Asus Transformer Prime is now the
low end of tablet resolution.
There's very few tablets that have a lower
resolution than this.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, if you can't do a 720p set
of artwork, you may just want to skip tablets
altogether.
>> GALPIN: I mean, I actually, you know, it's
funny because it depends on the game.
Like this game actually looks much better.
And again...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> GALPIN: ...it's making use of more--it's
making use of more fonts and it doesn't have
text that's rendered outside the font other
than, I think, this gem bonus one over here.
And, you know, it makes--it makes--it makes
a really big difference, you know, the game
feels much more like it's actually designed
for this resolution or so, you know..
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...whenever possible, use outlined
fonts.
I think that's just basically become the--that's
basically become the kind of gold standard
here.
So--and it looks like, you know, again, what
I'm excited of which I haven't gotten to in
this--in a lot of these games is actually
getting to the--is getting to the bonus round.
>> NI-LEWIS: See, I have to [INDISTINCT] I
think that those outlined fonts over the top
of those oysters look terrible.
I think that--I mean they're legible for some
definition of legible but...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they just look pasted on.
I meant they don't like they're part of the
artwork at all.
>> GALPIN: Oh, no, no.
I know that.
I didn't say the art design is actually--is
actually good for that.
I mean that's--you still have to design around
the fact that you have outlined fonts there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: You know, I think that's--I would
totally agree with you, you know, in that
sense but at least I'm not like--my eye--I'm
not squinting trying to see them and my eyes
are not drawn to them and trying to focus
on them which is really the key.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, you know what I've seen done
that would actually be really effective in
a game like this is do all of your graphics
in something like SPG.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
Yeah.
That's cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: And it's good for the SPG renders,
it worked great on a--on android.
You remember Bouncy Mouse did that?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I absolutely--what, you know, and it's actually
the code that was used inside of Androidify
and it's actually available in open source.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: And it's a really nice SPG to Android
canvas render essentially.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So, you can take your Illustrator files or
whatever and import them instead of rasterizing
them and importing them as bitmaps.
You import them as SPG which is usually a
much smaller format and is going to render
beautifully at almost any resolution.
And especially as screens get denser, that
becomes very, very important.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I know it's a good--it's a great way of keeping
the game size small.
And you have to be careful, obviously, because
it's very, very easy to create really, really
large SPG files too, you know...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...if you use certain effects like
as you start using lots of gradients, you're
like, "No.
Don't you--don't put the gradients in your
SPG files."
Actually, render those separately because
it's--a lot of SPG exporters will just, you
know, throw in tons and tons and tons of geometry
into the SPG.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, like everything else, there's
no magic bullet.
But I think this could really benefit from
the vectorize especially since, you know,
it's a sort of thing you draw at once and
then you're done.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, you can--you could
rasterize for this particular resolution and
then cache it if you want it to.
So, it's not like you're spending a huge amount
of CPU to make it look nice.
>> GALPIN: Now, you know, now--other things
that's interesting about this, it actually
has a swipe mechanic there which is kind of
nice, very obvious.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I like these screens.
They look good.
They're, you know, they're big...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...but, you know, as I get older
and frailer, I don't mind that much.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Well, I think--and I think that's really target
the audience we're talking about here.
You know, it's a somewhat older audience,
you know, we find that younger people are
tend to play this lots less and very, very
much like in the casinos.
It is--it is an older audience.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: So, it makes sense to make sure
everything's really, really legible, very,
very much in your face, how the...
>> NI-LEWIS: Big touch targets.
>> GALPIN: Big touch targets, yeah, I mean
this is--this is--this is a nice design.
>> NI-LEWIS: Also, you know, this is a good--we
talk a lot with Android about poor use of
gradients.
This is a good use of gradients.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: These buttons look good.
They don't look bubbly.
They don't look eye--like you're over using
the gradient effect.
You just got a slight little effect on those
so that they don't, like, completely flat
and that--I think that's appropriate in the
game style.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
And it really does feel like you've been--if
you've been to, you know, Vegas and seen the
way the casinos market these games, you know,
it does really feel like there's a lot of
commonality between this and the way the casinos
are actually marketing the games in Vegas.
So, you know, I say, you know, this is a really
nice job.
I see there's no reason, to be honest, why
they wouldn't feature this, other then there's
so many games alike and the competition is
fierce.
You know, if you're going to make a...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...slots game, be prepared to really
have to spend to drive people to it because
there's just so much competition in this area.
There are so many good games.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Well--and of course you're competing with
some really large social network players.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
Big contender.
And including GSN, GSN is not a small player
either.
So, you know, let's, you know, this is--if
you're in the spades and then I, you know,
by all means, and you're interested in making
slot games, make awesome slot games because
it's--and not--and be prepared to not just
make an awesome slot game but be prepared
to spend a lot of money to drive people to
it because...
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> GALPIN: ...because it's, you know, this
is one of those times where, you know, you
know the game model, the station model's really
straightforward and...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...you know, there's a lot of--there's
a lot of people here that would love to be
playing--get in your mind by slots.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
These games are not hard to program.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: They need a lot of art but programming
and us [INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: And design.
There's a lot of design makers into this...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...to make it--to make it, you
know, so it does do all those things and...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...hats off to those people but
it's not a technical issue.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Well, one of these days when I get sick of
being a good person, I'm totally going to
go Vegas and write slot machine code.
I hear they make a ton of money in a way.
So, let's get...
>> GALPIN: There's no way going to happen.
>> NI-LEWIS: I have some friends out there
and they are good people out there.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: They're really good people.
>> GALPIN: Oh, absolutely.
No, no, I'm...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, some are.
The Dark Nebula is probably the most interesting
game.
I'm glad we saved it for last.
It's a--it's a really interesting--now this
is one of those things--honestly, I'm always
sad when I see this over 6,000,000 downloads
on iOS and 5,000 download on Android.
And why is that, Dan?
>> GALPIN: I assume that it's because it just
hasn't gotten in front of a lot of people.
And that's, you know...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...ultimately that's...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you know, I'm going to
say that's true but also, you know, this is
really telling too because the first thing
you see on this page is Dark Nebula is finally
available on Android.
>> GALPIN: Well, that's also get, you know,
when you--when you bring out a game and you
bring [INDISTINCT] out of excitement, you
know, at another platform and then, a year
later, two years later, you drag the game
over to Android.
Why?
It's, you know, you've kind of reduced the
ability to get any press out of, kind of,
the general press.
And, you know, the game is really big on iOS,
you might end up seeing--getting some traction
that way but usually, it's actually sort of,
"All right.
Well, it's here.
Finally.
Great."
And it's been eclipsed by a bunch of other
games.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
It's been eclipsed and usually your marketing
dollars are gone, et cetera.
Now, as far as their featured graphic though,
I--their icon says a lot about what the game
is like and except for the stupid rounded
corners which totally don't need to be there...
>> GALPIN: Yup.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I like it.
Their featured graphic is clean and legible,
but it tells me nothing beyond the name of
the game.
>> GALPIN: I thought it was a space exploration
they way I saw it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And then you hear Dark Nebula and you're like,
"Oh, I bet there's going to be like, some,
you know...
>> GALPIN: I want it--I want it [INDISTINCT]
spaceship.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...a spaceship with some planets
and stuff, right?
>> GALPIN: And I want--and I want it like
exploration and yeah...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
>> GALPIN: And that is not the game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Basically, if you took this to
a design committee made up of like art school
seniors and say, "Hey, give me a design for
an ad for something called Dark Nebula."
And they'd be like, "What?
Is it a game?
Is it a vodka?"
>> GALPIN: We're not going to tell you anything
about it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Just some Dark Nebula.
>> GALPIN: Just the Dark Nebula.
>> NI-LEWIS: This is what...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they would come up with.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, totally.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, I think, you know, you can
do better I think it's actually...
>> GALPIN: Stop that.
Stop that.
It is--that's a little less blurry though.
To be honest [INDISTINCT] art students.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's--well, you never know because
sometimes art students get artsy.
>> GALPIN: That's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: But the point is, it has nothing
to do with the actual game which is more of
a combination of pinball and Labyrinth.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's a--you better take that
out actually.
I don't know.
Can you play the game with that?
It's a total [INDISTINCT].
>> GALPIN: Sure.
I actually--I actually played it sideways
last time I played it.
So, we'll see whether I can actually play
it successfully.
>> Ni-LEWIS: Dan will do anything to avoid
undocking the keyboard of his Asus Transformer
Prime.
>> GALPIN: It's true actually.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm not even sure why.
Why does he feel this way?
What deep seated need does this satisfy?
>> GALPIN: That's a very good question.
I think--I think we'll get to that in the
future episode.
>> NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
>> GALPIN: So, one thing you do you have to
hold in the correct orientation when you start
because that's when it calibrates itself.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
If you don't get calibrated you're screwed.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
So, that's why how you [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, really?
That's how you calibrate it?
You like that calibration?
>> GALPIN: I know.
I think actually it's one of those things
where it's probably better to tell you but
by the way really make sure to hold it in
the right orientation or otherwise you are
going to find that it's not going to be calibrated.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
This is one of those things where a little
bit of AI might go a along way just trying
to understand exactly what the player's trying
to do.
Because, you know, in general the range of
tilt-sensor for--that's is useful for game
play...
>> GALPIN: Actually...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is going to be much smaller
than the actual range of the sensor.
So, if you start seeing that the user is going
off one side or the other what a really good
game it will do is just sort of adjust it
so that they can...
>> GALPIN: It's hard to see [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: You kind of like--you kind of
calibrate as you're going.
>> GALPIN: I think, you know, it's funny.
I never actually tried playing this game with
the HDMI and I think it's not real happy about
the kind of jerky resizing that happens when
you--when you actually or have the HDMI plugged
in.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah, and you accidentally
taking it out.
Do you want to put it on my Nexus 7 and put
the--put the [INDISTINCT] camera on?
>> GALPIN: Yeah, you might want to [INDISTINCT]
the camera.
Let's just try this one more time to see if
I can actually get through.
So, one thing that's really great about this
game is actually the accelerometer controls
are really precise.
They do want you wanted to do, like honestly...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...it actually feels really, really
good.
And that's I think the most important thing
in this kind of a game is that you're going
to use accelerometer controls and, you know,
I am not always a fan of accelerometer controls.
I'd be the first one to say...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...that it is actually messed up
quite a lot of really good games.
But in this game, you know, the game is entirely
designed around it which is why it works.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, if you're using the new
API's that we shipped in--what was that?
ICS?
Then you can get really, really incredibly
good accelerometer.
If you don't use a new API's or if you're
on an older device then the accelerometer
is a little bit flaky.
>> GALPIN: Now, one thing I love about the
game play in this is that you actually have
to--you see go and in order to open doors
you actually have to go over certain areas
and it gives your, you know, character this--what
kind of red or green and force field.
SO I've got this red force field and now the
red force field allows me to get through that
wall, et cetera and so forth.
So, there's a lot of really good elements
here in the game play that, you know, I really
enjoyed.
And, you know, I...
>> NI-LEWIS: And it is cool.
I mean, it feels--can you fall off the edge
there by the way or...
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
Yes.
So, it's kind of get that marble madness thing
going on.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
No.
It's a really nice design for an [INDISTINCT]
based game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: You know, I love to see people
who are--you're doing an [INDISTINCT] base
game actually going and saying, "No, we're
going to design around this input method and
really try to do something cool."
That's always, you know, that's always better
than kind of throwing it into an existing
AIM design.
And so, you know, you know, thumbs up to the
designers.
Oh, yeah, look at that.
I just died.
My shield it down.
I'm about to die.
>> NI-LEWIS: But you're right.
It is a fun game.
There's a few--a few sprites seem a little
low res but that could just be the angle I'm
holding it aside.
>> GALPIN: No, it's definitely--it's definitely
gotten some minor resolution issues.
It's, you know, it looks like it's one resolution
step below what we have here...
>> NI-LEWIS: Got you.
Yeah, and that's...
>> GALPIN: ...on the ASUS Transformer Prime.
>> NI-LEWIS: We have a YouTube question?
>> Let's see.
>> NI-LEWIS: You have been dedicated to reading
YouTube questions like a good producer right,
Alex?
>> There haven't been any comments in the
past several minutes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Really?
>> So, I think our time switch has injured
our viewership or people are just quiet today.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's possible.
>> The last actual question was about the
music from the Agent Shooter game.
>> GALPIN: There you go.
>> NI-LEWIS: Wow.
>> Yeah.
My--the only problem I have with the UI for
this game for the tilting thing.
I think in general [INDISTINCT] works really
well.
The only problem I have with it is you get
to a point where in order to go forward and
you're tilting the screen away from you and
that makes actually...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> ...it seem what you're doing difficult.
So, what you're doing is like, if it's like
this.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> You end up going like this and you almost
have to sort of lean over and [INDISTINCT]
whatever it was you're doing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I noticed that.
And despite what Dan was saying about calibration.
If I hold it like this while the level is
starting it still wants to lie flat...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...while I'm playing it.
>> Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's not cool guys.
>> Yeah, if there's...
>> Ni-LEWIS: Totally not cool.
>> If there was just a way to or to have it
calibrate for holding in front of you like
a 45 degree angle or something like that.
So, you tilt it a little that you can still
see perfectly what's going on.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or if I had a specially built
table with like Leonardo Da Vinci [INDISTINCT]
and stuff coming out...
>> GALPIN: That would be so cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: I know--I would love...
>> [INDISTINCT] pulling on ropes and stuff.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
>> GALPIN: I want to see--I want to see like
Labyrinth peripheral for this guy.
That would be awesome.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Right.
But as it stands, yeah, control is good but
could be a lot better if you would just let
it...
>> GALPIN: So, here's how you actually do
it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: It's actually in the game.
There's actually a calibration.
You can calibrate...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...it here or oh, you can--and
you can actually calibrate and during the
game.
This is what I hadn't noticed because it's
kind of hidden in there but you actually--you
actually recalibrate the game by pressing
the screen with two fingers.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: So, there we are.
It's calibrated here.
Let's see how much more playable it is.
So, you know, again, may this be a question
of just being able to find this because obviously
neither--none of us found it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, that's interesting because
it does a lot a better but it's also a lot
more jerky for some reason.
>> GALPIN: Really?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: I don't understand that.
Yeah.
Well...
>> GALPIN: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it does help though.
>> It's good that it's possible to recalibrate.
But I would seriously consider the switching
your default over to someone holding it in
front of you either vertically or 45 degrees.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
What is tricky like, you don't like honestly,
because of the design of the game maybe if
you calibrate it too far up it also becomes
really hard to play.
>> Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, so, since it's obviously
very quick to calibrate it.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: What I don't understand is why
wouldn't I just calibrate it every time--every
time I start.
Let's say...
>> GALPIN: I have...
>> NI-LEWIS: So, give it, you know, give it
a little count down, you know, you got three
seconds and then you're going to go.
And the average player is going to put it
into the position where they don't want it
to move.
And the last thing you want to do is have
your balls start to move when you start.
So, I don't know.
Maybe that's just me.
But yeah, this accelerometer is not nearly
as, oh my goodness, it's--no, it's almost
unplayable when I calibrate it to a 45 degree
angle.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, it is--it really...
>> NI-LEWIS: But I don't understand why.
>> GALPIN: I'm not sure either.
There's a problem...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that would be really interesting
to find out.
>> GALPIN: So, in any case, you know, we really
like Dark Nebula.
I think it's a, you know, it's a game that,
you know, that we all enjoyed playing and,
you know, I think it's a little hard to play
when you have it plugged in HDMI and you're
trying desperately to keep the HDMI from getting
pulled out.
But it...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So, if you have that problem.
You might want to stir clear this one.
But, other than that...
>> GALPIN: But, you know, it's really, a really
thoroughly welcome track of game.
And I, you know, I honestly say this, I'm
looking forward to going through and getting
higher and higher level in the game.
>> NI-LEWIS: It is a really fun game.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: I love it.
>> GALPIN: We know, I--and this is--I bought
this game.
So, I know personally.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Nice.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Isn't that because we made you?
>> GALPIN: It's true but I did.
So, that's...
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Well...
>> GALPIN: All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Redhook ESB, five great games.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we are out of here.
So, thanks a lot for watching The Friday Review.
Remember, that next week we will once again
have an open topic.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, go ahead and nominate whatever
you want just please, please, please put a
link to it.
I'm talking to you, Dark Nebula guy.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And give us your info so if we
get around to it and we're not too drunk and
we're, you know, feeling good that day.
We'll try and invite you onto a G+ hang out
at some point.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
It's great--it's great to have developers
when they come online and we can talk to them
about the games and kind of get an idea of,
you know, why certain design decisions were
made.
So, it's always great if you're available
at this time which is now 12:00 noon PST to
actually go and join us live on the show.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, we're going to go ahead and
keep it at noon PST for a week.
It looks like nobody watches at that time.
We might switch, it's cool.
Let us know.
Our only ask is that it needs to be some point
within shouting distance of working hours
for us and preferably within drinking hours.
So...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
9:00...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...nothing before 9:00 AM.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, 9:00 in the morning is kind
of the cut.
I refuse to drink before 9:00 so...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Because at 9:00 we've only just stop drinking.
We don't want to start again.
>> GALPIN: So, have a great weekend everyone
and definitely continue to vote on the moderator
page and nominate your games and your favorite
games and let's see some great stuff for next
week.
Actually, it was--it was a really fun week.
I hope there's a lot of really...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, there are some good stuff.
I really like--I think the quality of submissions
has really gone up.
So, we appreciate it.
Thanks for watching Happy Android play this
out.